آه في غضون ساعة واحدة فقط ،
ما نتوقعه هو أنه ستكون هناك
نتيجة صحيحة أخرى ، سنحصل على جزء آخر
من البيانات من مقاطعة ماريكوبا حيث
يقومون بفرز الأصوات بجد
ونتوقع أن تكون هذه آخر
جزء من معلومات الاقتراع  التي سنحصل
عليها اليوم ، لذا أريد نوعًا من
إرشادك خلال
بعض الأشياء التي رأيناها تحدث
في الساعات القليلة الماضية أو
لذلك أريد أن أبدأ هنا لأن هؤلاء
هم الأشخاص الطيبون الذين يعملون هنا
عد التصويت يؤدي المهمة
وأنت تعرف في بعض الأحيان المهمة الشاقة
للديمقراطية الأمريكية
الآن سأجعلك تتبعني بهذه
الطريقة والسبب في أننا نسير على هذا النحو
هو أنه كان هناك وضع أمني
هنا في ماريكوبا  قسم انتخابات
المقاطعة وهذا الوضع الأمني
يفن مايرز ، لذا تقدم للأمام قليلاً فقط يم
نك رؤية خط إن
اذ القانون هنا قسم العمدة وح
د كبير جدًا إن
مضاء  يصعب عليّ
تحديد حجم
هذا الحشد بالضبط ولكن يمكنك أن ترى
بنفسك أن
هناك الكثير من القبعات الحمراء ، وهناك
الكثير من علامات ترامب
وهناك الكثير من
الترانيم أريد أن أذكر الجميع هنا أن
هذا
خارج  في المكتب حيث يقومون
بفرز الأصوات
حيث نأمل في
معرفة المزيد عن
الطريقة التي ستذهب بها الأصوات الانتخابية الأحد عشر
في
ولاية أريزونا ، يواصل الكثير من الأشخاص بالداخل
القيام بهذا
العمل المهم للغاية وهم كبار السن ،
وهذا هو  ما يرونه وهم
يحاولون القيام بذلك